دعني أخبرك أنك تعرف بالضبط ما
قصدته أن الرئيس ترامب قال مرارًا وتكرارًا
إنه كان يمزح أو يستخدم السخرية
لتحييد بعض ملاحظاته الأكثر
إثارة للجدل هذه مجرد
بعض التعليقات التي تراجع عنها الرئيس ترامب أو
حلفاؤه لاحقًا قائلين
إنه كان كذلك.  سواء كان يمزح أو
يسخر عندما جعلك تضرب
القاضي روسيا إذا كنت تستمع ، آمل
أن تتمكن من العثور على ثلاثين ألف
رسالة بريد إلكتروني مفقودة للصين ،
بدأت تحقيقًا في الجثة
لأن ما حدث في الصين هو على
وشك  سيئًا مثل ما حدث مع
أوكرانيا ، فنحن نبني جدارًا على
حدود نيو مكسيكو
ونبني جدارًا في كولورادو ، فنحن نبني
جدارًا جميلًا ، جدارًا كبيرًا
يعمل حقًا ولا يمكنك تجاوزه  لا يمكن أن
نحصل عليه ونحن نبني جدارًا في
تكساس ولا نبني جدارًا في
كانساس لكنهم يستفيدون من
الجدران التي ذكرناها للتو أرى
المطهر حيث يكسرها في
دقيقة واحدة دقيقة  هل هناك طريقة يمكننا من
خلالها القيام بشيء من هذا القبيل عن طريق الحقن
بالداخل أو التنظيف تقريبًا لأنك
ترى أنه يدخل في الرئتين ويؤدي
عددًا هائلاً لفترة طويلة ، لذا سيكون من
المثير للاهتمام التحقق من أنه لكي نكون منصفين
مع الرئيس ، فإن السخرية هي  من الواضح أنه
متعمد في بعض الحالات أنني
الشخص المختار ، لكنه في بعض الأحيان يلقي
ملاحظات بطريقة غامضة فقط ليدعي لاحقًا
أنه كان يمزح هناك وكان
يمزح ، لذلك وضعوا الأمر
بشكل يجعل من الصعب على الأمريكيين
والقادة الأجانب معرفة متى يأخذونه على
محمل الجد  من الصعب أيضًا على
الرئيس أن يدحض عندما يتم التقاطها
بالكاميرا
ما الذي كان يقصده الآن فقط عندما قلت
أن
الأمريكيين سيجلسون
منتبهًا معك ، فأنا أمزح ، فأنت لا تفهم
[موسيقى]
من أنت معك مع CNN